the first group of shuttle astronauts in
his new memoir writing rockets he spoke
about it recently for 35 minutes
good evening borders customers before we
begin I would like to welcome our
friends at book TV who will be filming
tonight's discussion we look forward to
hearing any questions you have for Mike
tonight but we also want the future book
TV viewers to hear your questions also
so with that in mind when you would like
to ask a questions please wait for the
microphone to come to you before asking
the questions so that the book TV
viewers can see just how smart you
really are tonight Borders is pleased to
welcome Mike Mullane as he discusses his
new book writing Rockets the outrageous
tales of a space shuttle astronauts
writing Rockets is the first book by
space shuttle astronauts to write about
his Space Shuttle experiences for adult
audiences unlike prior astronaut books
which tend to be g-rated technical and
sanitized Mullane story is refreshingly
human Edie candid from a Sputnik era
childhood of launching homemade rockets
to writing a space shuttle into orbit
melanne recounts the stories of an
amazing dream quest upon his graduation
from West Point in 1967
melanne was commissioned into the UAS a
USAF he flew 134 combat missions in
Vietnam and he was selected and first
group of space shuttle astronauts he
completed the brief space missions and
he currently lives in Albuquerque New
Mexico please give a warm Border's
welcome to Mike Mullane ok thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen and good
evening I thought I would start here by
explaining what a shuttle launch is like
everybody has always asked me what it's
like to be out on that rocket what it's
like to fly in space and I'm gonna read
here and a little bit from a few
passages but extemporaneously I want to
describe to you what it's like to blast
off into space I'm frequently asked was
I afraid sitting out there on that
launch pad and I reply no I was not
afraid I was terrified it goes well
beyond being afraid folks and the reason
I say that is unlike a fighter jet where
you're sitting on an ejection seat you
feel like if things really go bad you
can always have a chance of bailing out
and a space shuttle you don't have that
option there is no escape system so once
you get
once you're in it you know that
everything has to work work just fine or
else bad things could happen so it's a
significant fear factor sitting out
there on that launchpad
now when the motors ignite you get a
heavy vibration it really rattled you
just really shakes you good the
countdown will continue to zero when the
solid rocket boosters ignite the
hold-down bolts blow and you're on your
way about 40 seconds in a flight you're
doing supersonic they've got a lot of
shock waves on the vehicle from the gas
tank and the in the rocket boosters so
you're really really bouncing around
pretty good at t minus e me at t plus
two minutes and 12 seconds two minutes
and 12 seconds after liftoff you'll hear
this loud bang you'll see this fire
across the windows as these boosters are
explosively separated and then it gets
dead quiet for the next six and a half
minutes you'll continue into space on
the three liquid fueled engines they're
burning liquid oxygen out of liquid
hydrogen out of that big orange gas tank
but it's very smooth very quiet the only
way you can tell you're moving are the
g-forces slowly pushing in you into your
seat and those will stabilize at three
times the force of gravity that is not
like the science fiction movies where
you see people's faces being peeled back
off their skull it's not like that but
it does feel like somebody's sitting on
you it's a little hard to breathe and
hard to talk at three times the force of
gravity eight and a half minutes up the
gas tank is empty the autopilot shuts
off the engines that gas tank is
jettison it tumbles in the atmosphere
and burns up like a giant meteor we fire
two small engines at the tail of the
winged vehicle we have gas for those in
the tail area we fire those for a couple
minutes to give us an extra boost of a
couple hundred miles an hour of speed to
put us into our final orbit somewhere
between about 100 and 400 miles above
the earth depending on the mission and
that entire process that I just
described to you from liftoff
zero altitude zero speed to being in an
orbit around 200 miles above the earth
that entire process takes just 10
minutes so very short violent and
frankly terrifying 10 minutes okay what
I'd like to do now is just read a couple
passages from the book then we'll open
up for questions and then we'll do do
the book signing here and if anybody at
the time of the book signing wants to
take a photo standing next to me will
just sign the book and stand next to me
and we'll take a photo alright so think
of your questions and we'll
that was here when we're done I had a
dream come true early in my life I
dreamed of being an astronaut and this
book is about that quest you know to
make that dream happen I wanted to share
with you a passage here I was reborn on
October 4th 1957 anybody know what
happened that date yes Sputnik was
launched I was 12 years old growing up
in Albuquerque New Mexico sky out in
Albuquerque was great to be looking for
satellites and looking for stars it was
easy to see him coming over coming over
the house in fact I could just step
outside of my house in Albuquerque and I
was in space it was so so black but I
thought I would just describe to you and
one paragraph here remembering back to
that moment of watching Sputnik come
over that evening I stood with the rest
of the city population in the cold
October Twilight to watch the new
Russian moon twinkle overhead my dad
watched from his wheelchair
my dad was crippled with polio when he
was 33 and spent the rest of his life in
a wheelchair and I developed that also
in this book that the effect that had on
me for the rest of my life of having a
father that was confined to a wheelchair
my dad watched from his from his
wheelchair cursing Eisenhower for being
asleep at the switch I was struck dumb
by the spectacle the paper had said the
object would be moving at 17,000 miles
per hour 150 miles in the sky I was
mesmerized by the thought of traveling
at such speeds and altitudes the
newspaper had said men would do it
someday the sight the the science
fiction movies of my youth had long
depicted man spaceships flying to
distant planets now Sputnik proved that
was really going to happen there would
be spaceships I couldn't imagine a more
exciting adventure and I wanted to be
part of it I wanted to fly in space now
I'm gonna speed forward here and talk to
you about the the moment that you get
assigned I mean getting there's a lot of
special moments in an astronauts life a
lot of them and getting assigned to a
flight is one but there's always a lot
of flights in front of you when you're
assigned to that flight the big really
big moment that you celebrate as an
astronaut is when your prime crew
when the next mission is going to be
your mission and that that happened for
me on Friday the 13th in 1984 when the
mission in front of us my first mission
it landed and now we were next and I
just want to describe to you my feelings
of that moment we were next
we were prime crew with that title came
top priority for simulators and t-38 for
me it also brought prime crew night to
prime crew night terrors until this
moment every time my soul tried to deal
with the fear and joy of what was fast
approaching I disallowed it STS 6 is I
u.s. failure STS 9s hydraulic fire and
STS 41 Peas twin satellite booster
failures had made me a skeptic there was
too much in front of us that could
jeopardize our mission even now with
horizon clear of any other shuttle
missions I kept my emotions on a very
short leash until the hold-down bolts
blew there were no guarantees an engine
could blow up in a ground test and stop
the program my health could become an
issue the payload contractors could find
something seriously wrong with their
machines there were thousands of
unknowns in this business don't even
think about flying in space I ordered
myself and during my waking hours I
obeyed that order I had plenty of
distractions however in sleep the
reality of being prime crew would creep
past my defenses
I would bolt awake with my heart wildly
drumming in my brain overwhelmingly
aware that I would be next off the
planet every fear I had ever harbored
about death aboard a space shuttle every
doubt I'd ever held about my confidence
to do the mission every joy I'd ever
ever celebrated at the thought of flying
into space would flash through my
consciousness in a wild chaotic fury and
vaporize any hope for a further sleep I
would get up and go for a walk or a run
I want to skip here to talk a little bit
about the drama that the spouses
experienced in this business and I think
I've done a good job in this book of
really bringing them in unlike I think
other other astronaut books they pay a
significant part obviously and making a
dream come true my wife certainly had
played a huge
part in my life and but she paid a price
it was a grueling emotional
heart-rending effort for her to support
me in this business and one of the
things that the spouses have to do is
about a month before launch they have to
get together and select what's called an
astronaut escort that is a euphemism
these people are standing next to the to
the spouses on the roof of the launch
control center and will be there
during the launch to help if any
disasters happen so my I want to pick up
with that background knowing that my
wife has just selected or is selecting
one of these astronaut escorts I'll read
this paragraph there were no formal
criteria for selection of family escorts
crew spouses usually threw out a few
names to consider and quickly settled on
to our spouses dick Covey and Brian
O'Connor as their escorts unspoken in
their deliberations was another duty for
which the family escorts were being
selected if discovery killed us they
would become casualty assistance
officers I suspected every wife knew
this even if the husbands were now even
if their husbands were negligent and not
telling them they probably heard it from
other wives
I had told Donna years earlier NASA
required her and the kids to watch my
launches with the family escorts from
the roof of the launch control center
it wasn't the view NASA had in mind NASA
wanted to isolate the families from the
press in the event of a disaster in that
case the family escorts turned casualty
assistance officers would drive them to
the Kennedy Space Flight Center flight
operations where a NASA jet would whisk
him back back to Houston that evening on
the ride back from a party that evening
on the ride back from the party Donna
turned to me and said this is a strange
business when you have to pre-select
an escort into widowhood she was
enduring a lot for my dream and all the
wives did for their spouses I had this
dream of becoming an astronaut come true
on August 30th 1984 on my first launch
it was the first launch of the orbiter
discovery and I just thought I would
share with you the thrill of what it's
like when that moment occurs in that
moment
there's a technical requirement that
says when you pass 50 miles altitude
you're an astronaut that spaceship one
you heard about in the news that was one
of their objectives was to be able to
get up to those type of altitudes
because by by some long defined deaf
long ago definition 50 miles to find you
as a as an astronaut we were approaching
50 miles the magic line that would
officially make us astronauts I'd always
thought this altitude requirement was
bean-counter BS effectively it was a
statement that riding a rocket didn't
really get dangerous until you hit 50
miles in reality if you didn't make it
to 50 miles on the shuttle it probably
meant the machine had killed you as was
later to be the case with the Challenger
crew Mike Smith was a rookie killed on
that mission and by the official
definition he didn't die as an astronaut
since he had only made it to ten miles
altitude and in parentheses I have note
to NASA when the hold-down bolts blow
you've earned your gold and that is very
very true
continuing here Hank gave us the
countdown hank was the commander of the
mission here it comes
48 49 50 miles congratulations rookies
you're officially astronauts we cheered
I suspect
Judy Steve Mike and Charlie were
relishing the moment as I was
I experienced a momentary calm not
unlike what I expect someone summiting
Mount Everest experiences there were
still a few thousand things that could
kill me but their threat couldn't tug me
away from the moment I stared into the
black and watched images of my childhood
play in my mind's eye I saw my homemade
rocket streep streaking upward from the
Albuquerque deserts for my I saw my
homemade rocket streaking upward from
the Albuquerque deserts my dad on his
crutches cheering I saw my mom helping
me bake my fuels in her oven and
cleaning our cleanin out coffee cans for
my capsules
I saw myself lying in the desert
watching Sputnik and echo streaked
across the Twilight I had achieved a
dream of 10,000 nights I was an
astronaut okay one of the things to the
beauty of the earth seen from space is
as I say in here when it's really would
be an insult to God to really put
in human words to to see the Earth from
space I know probably a lot of you have
seen photos of Grand Canyon and thought
wow this is pretty great and then you
stand there and in the photo that you
saw doesn't compare to that grandeur and
that's the way it is with flying into
space it is truly it challenges to
describe how beautiful it is but I try
as everybody does and here's my shot at
a description of one of the more
beautiful sights you can see from space
and that is a sunset the 45 minutes of
my orbit date drew to an end and I was
treated to another spaceflight of such a
breathtaking beauty it would challenge
the most gifted poet as discovery raced
eastward behind her the Sun plunged
toward the western horizon beneath me
the Terminator that hazy shadow that
separates brilliant daylight from the
deep black of night began to dim the
crenelated ocean blue high clouds over
this Terminator glow tangerine & pink in
the final rays of the Sun discovery
entered this shadow world and I turned
my head to the back windows to watch the
Sun dipped below the horizon it's light
which to this moment had been as pure
white as a baby soul was now being split
by the atmosphere an intense color
spectrum a hundred times more brilliant
than any rainbow seen on earth formed in
an arc to separate the black of Earth
night from the perennial black of space
where it touched the earth the color bow
was as red as royal velvet and faded
upward through multiple shades of orange
and blue and purple until it dissipated
into the black as discovery sped far
farther from it the boat slowly shrank
along the Earth's limb toward the point
of sunset diminishing and reach and
thickness and intensity as if the colors
were a liquid being drained from the sky
finally only an eyelash then arc of
indigo remained then it winked out in
discovery was fully immersed in the
Oblivion of orbit night let me tell you
a little story here the I was in the
first group of astronauts that was that
included female astronauts we're the
first group of space shuttle selected in
the space shuttle era 29 men six women
Sally Ride Judy Resnik Rhea Seddon were
some of the some of the females that I
were that were my classmates one of the
things that I noticed was the pressure
the women were under to never exhibit
any any any to show any difference
between men they knew they were under a
microscope by the press that was
searching for them to show any
difference between them and a male
astronaut and sometimes it manifests
itself in strange ways on my first
mission I was flying with Judy Resnik
she was subsequently killed on
Challenger but we were flying our first
mission together in 1984 and we had an
IMAX camera the one that we filmed
scenes from that IMAX movie narrated by
Walter Cronkite the dream is alive it's
a big camera and it has a belt-driven
magazine on it on earth it weighs about
a hundred hundred pounds and it's very
loud when its operating and my commander
was filming a satellite deployment Judy
if any of you remember she had really
bushy black hair and it wasn't up in
weightlessness it's all about her head
and we're deploying a satellite and yeah
I hear this scream and it's Judy's hair
got caught in that that belt-driven
magazine just like like getting caught
in a fan belt of a car and it just
pulled her head down into that thing and
I grabbed it and of course in
weightlessness you can't you know have
anything to react against so we're all
tumbling in the middle of the cockpit
I'm trying to keep her hair from getting
ripped out of her scalp by this machine
it's chomping it in there and then it
happened pretty quickly but the Machine
Jam the camera jammed when her hair got
stuck in the gearing and a circuit
breaker popped in a stop and mike coates
our pilot spent hours picking hair out
of that gearing to get that camera to
work that's floating all over the
cockpit was and our eyes and our inner
mouths you know it was a kind of a
little mess up there in the cockpit but
I want to pick up at that point now
we've we've jammed this camera with
Judy's hair remembering the the issue of
never revealing that you're different
than males and obviously females have
bigger hair than us males do and in many
cases and certainly Judy did so let me
read a paragraph on how this all played
out
Hank is getting ready Hank Hartsfield is
getting ready to pick up the microphone
and call Mission Control tell them the
the cameras not working because of this
hair jam and they're gonna have to
replan the tar
that we were filming and okay with that
background but we males had been missing
the real issue as Hank picked up the
microphone to call MCC Judy lashed out
lashed out at him with something along
the lines of if you so much as breathe a
word to MCC about my hair jam in the
camera I'll cut your heart out with a
spoon or perhaps she threatened a more
vital area of his Anatomy there was a
brief moment as we struggle to
understand Judy's rage then it dawned on
us she was only the second American
woman to fly in space the press had her
under a magnifying glass looking for the
slightest flaw in her performance the
hair jam incident was just that a
mistake with her name on it not only
that it contained the worst possible sin
against feminism Judy had demonstrated
however innocently and however in
significantly that women were indeed
different from men hank Hartsfield a
grizzled Air Force fighter pilot who had
stared death in the eye on many a
mission now faced a man's worst
nightmare a really pissed-off woman no
communist gunner had ever appeared as
deadly as did Judy at that moment under
her searing glare Hank did what we all
would have done he wanted to return with
all of his appendages so he called MCC
and told him the IMAX camera had a film
jam and Mike was working to clear it he
made no mention of the cause of the jam
eventually mike was able to breathe life
back into the camera with rescheduled
targets he and Hank continued their
filming while Judy stayed far far away
yeah tell you another story I'm not
gonna read from but another interesting
another example of how this played out
is on this mission our toilet by the way
is a vacuum cleaner do not try this at
home folks but it's it is a vacuum
cleaner and the urinal on ours failed
about three or four days into the
mission so we can no longer use the
urinal and had to pee in plastic bags
now as you imagine it's hard enough in
weightlessness for men to be doing that
females at sea it's gonna obviously be
worse and the ground went back and
looked at their figures and found that
there was a enough space in the urine
collection tank and they cryptically
sent this message to us there's two man
days or three man days or whatever of
space remaining in that time
and the message was clear to all of us
us men would have to pee in the plastic
bags and Judy could use the continue to
use the urinal and use that last space
in the tank Judy would not use that
urinal because she knew that word would
eventually reach out or leak out that
she had been cut some slack because she
was a woman and she knew though she
couldn't do that to give you some idea I
mean nowadays that you know this all
sounds I know silly - probably a lot of
you but back in those days you got to
remember where those women were they
were under a magnifying glass by the
press okay I wanted to go back here
there was a one of the things that we do
in the in the space business that were
ill-prepared for not prepared for is
public speaking and we had no training
in that NASA expected us to go out and
just be as good flying rockets as at the
podium as we were flying rockets and
staring at that black camera back there
for for c-span I was reminded of this
passage right here the most dreaded form
of public speaking was a TV interview a
streak of anti-aircraft fire passing
your wing doesn't get your heart rate up
like looking into a black camera lens
and hearing three two one you're live
for me it was a cadence that always
brought on nausea once as I was
listening to this on the air countdown
the anchor leaned into me and said it's
just like a shuttle launch when you hit
zero there's no going back he was right
hearing your live was just like hearing
the rumble of SRB ignition you were
flying the camera was scattering your
images and words into the living rooms
of America and there would be no
do-overs I was sure my Adam's apple was
dancing like a bobblehead on a dashboard
and my fear widened eyes were darting
like minnows I imagine people at their
breakfast tables laughing as I choked
trying to respond to a simple question
like what's your name I'll tell you it
was tough getting used to being in the
limelight and having to develop some
skills at talking publicly I thought I'd
just close here with a with a one last
paragraph
down at Kennedy Space Center
there is a astronaut memorial that has
granite face that has the names of all
the astronauts who have died in the line
of duty chiseled into these granite
panels and the mirrors on the back that
reflect the light through these etchings
and these granite panels and I'm talking
about being a retired astronaut and
going down to the Kennedy Space Center
keeping in mind folks at four of my
classmates including Judy Resnik died on
challenger on my visits to the memorial
I will take a seat on a bench and stare
at the four T F and G was the name of
our class nickname of our class in
polite company it was 35 new guys
it had an obscene connotation which is
also described in this book but for
polite company it was 35 new guys
shortened to TF ng on my visits to the
memorial I will take a seat on a bench
and stare at the 40 F ng names the
panel's bare Francis dick Scobee Judith
a Resnick Ellison Onizuka and Ronald
McNair and remember the last moment I
saw them they were walking to a sim
wearing pine crew smiles it is how I
will always remember them young happy
soaring with the knowledge that they
were next up I will remember each of
them in my prayers I will also include a
prayer for their spouses and Judy's
family the life those spouses and
parents knew also ended on January 28
1986 but nobody ever edged their names
in a monument from the memorial I will
walk to a nearby full-scale Space
Shuttle mock-up metal platforms have
been installed around the display so
tourists can climb up and walk through
the cockpit
I will anonymously join a group of
families and watch them take photos and
listen to them marvel at the complexity
of the switch panels and the cramped
volume invariably my attention will be
drawn to a child among them and his or
her amazed young face I will be
transported back to 1957 I am standing
in my front lawn with you with the
identical expression watching Sputnik
one twinkle through the Terminator so I
thought I'd just share share some of
those readings with you give an idea the
writing style and what's a
here I would probably booksellers hate
me to say this value I would make this
comment this book is adult in nature
okay it is inappropriate for children
okay so if anybody was buying it here
for little Billy wait until little
Billy's over 18 before he reads it okay
or else he's he might be asking some
interesting questions in fact I guess I
will read the first opening sentence of
you for those of you who haven't
purchased the book it reads I was naked
lying on my side on a table in the NASA
flight medicine clinic bathroom probing
at my rear in with a nozzle of an enema
okay that's how it opens so I just want
everybody to understand that it's a very
real honest book about the experience I
think it captures a lot of the joy humor
and fear that we experience as
astronauts what the spouses experience I
think I think you would enjoy but I'm
happy to answer any questions now I
think we have to wait here for the for
the microphone to pass around and and I
know all of you are probably as
terrified as I was if anybody has a
question just feel free to raise a hand
there and we'll we'll get it for you
they got one right there okay far away
could you describe what it's like having
the the shuttle main engines ignite for
liftoff then shut down about three
seconds before launch okay his question
concerns my very first launch attempt in
June of 1984 the way the shuttle
countdown proceeds you get down to six
seconds the three liquid fueled engines
start why do we do that by the way why
don't we start those three liquid
engines six seconds early what can you
do with a liquid fueled engine you
cannot do with a solid fueled engine
turn it off so the computers check those
engines make sure they're all working
fine then if they pass all those checks
commands are sent to the solid rocket
boosters to the hold-down bolts they
blow boosters ignite and you're on your
way on my first launch attempt we got
down to those final seconds and as I
said you're terrified out there so
you're hearing they're you know you're
watching the clock eight seven six main
engines starting you thought had the
vibration I remember thinking as scared
as I was I was thinking I'm going now
whatever
happens I'm going now five four three
silence our engines when I'm was sick so
all of my shut shut down that took us by
surprise we had seen that scenario in
Train scenario in training but it had
been a long time and we just weren't up
on the step on that and it really
shocked us to all of a sudden have an
alarm going off in the cockpit warning
us that the engines have shut down and
then so now the vehicle is rocking back
and forth on the hole down bolts this
folks that had people ask me the scared
us I've ever been this was it the ground
then reports seeing a fire on the
launchpad not on the vehicle but some
insulation or something caught fire on
the launch pad we can't see that you
know but we hear that we hear that word
fire there so they turn on the fire
suppression system so water spraying all
over the vehicle all over the gantry and
man my heart is in my throat hearing
that word fire and the ground report
seeing a small fire on the launch pad
well when you're sitting on four million
pounds of propellant there's no such
thing as a small fire I remember looking
at Steve Hawley that's mission
specialist that was sitting next to me
his eyes were as big as saucers and I
knew I was looking in a mirror that was
my face now look at Holley and he looks
at me and he says gosh I thought we'd be
higher when the engines quit I wanted to
hit him there was nothing funny about
this Holley but it was scary I was a
terrifying minute or so while we came to
grips with what was actually happening
and obviously nothing serious did happen
the machine worked the way it was
designed and we came back a couple
months later and finally got I got space
born on August 30th okay other other
questions any other questions I'll
answer the OS I'm sorry could you tell
us your thoughts about retiring the
shuttle and replacing it with the CEV
which I understands still going to be
using some of the shuttle hardware that
the plan right now for the shuttle is
the new NASA Administrator after
Columbia came in and it was courageous
for him to do it but he said hey we've
got to stop flying the space shuttle
we're not going to get onto the Moon and
Mars with a space shuttle we're gonna
fly at the minimum number of times
to build out the International Space
Station then where to ground and he's
aiming for 2010 to have the shuttle
grounded at that point we will then go
to what's called a CV with crew
exploration vehicle which would look
very similar to the old rockets with a
multistage rocket on top a capsule with
a tractor escape rocket on top of it
it's back to the future in that design
but it's certainly much safer than the
shuttle and it will be a vehicle that
can ultimately get astronauts back to
the moon and on to Mars the shuttle is
not going to be able to go to the Moon
or Mars obviously so I I'm I'm
Foursquare behind that I think that's
the right the right future for for NASA
I think you had that one question which
surprised me you're such a great
motivational speaker it's hard for me to
believe that you're awkward at one time
did you fire okay the question the
question was is he said I'm such a great
motivational speaker it's hard to
imagine that I was ever like everybody
else you know that they're in fact old
Seinfeld it's a it's an old joke I saw
Seinfeld do it once in a stand-up you at
the eulogy you know here's the coffin
right there most people would rather be
in the coffin than delivering the eulogy
because of the fear of public speaking
it is really something that really does
scare scare all of us and I was that
away just as everybody else was and the
only reason that that I I do
professional speaking motivational
speaking on teamwork and leadership to
corporations around the country and and
I'm completely comfortable with that
because I've done it for so long and I
have my PowerPoint prepared program I'm
like everybody else if somebody at a
party or somebody says oh we have
astronaut Mike Mullane here why don't
you stand up and say a few words Mike
it's like my heart is in my throat I I
don't have a few words I can get my
computer and put my powerpoint program
up here but unlike everybody else
extemporary honestly talking about
things that you're really not not
completely prepared for so I learned
just like everything else you learn and
get better at it back got a couple here
how far along do you think we are
towards of breaking beyond the solar
system beyond the solar system I mean
that's hundred there's gonna have to be
a significant breakthrough in propulsion
to do something you know what does it
take us to get those unmanned probes to
Jupiter about six eight years or so and
then 13 years to Pluto or whatever it is
I mean the our lives are so short the
lifespan of humans are so short either
we're gonna have to come up some way of
doing the old suspended animation like
the science fiction movies are having
some propulsion system that's going to
be able to rapidly accelerate people to
tremendous speeds to make flight outside
of the solar system possible and I don't
know 100 years seem short to me I don't
know that's hard to guess thousand years
who knows other somebody else had a
question here well while their character
while the microphoned is moving over to
him I will answer I told you the first
ask question the most asked question I
ever hear is a toilet question how do
you go to the bathroom in space it is it
is a vacuum cleaner as I said the second
most asked question that I ever hear is
the alien question have I seen any
aliens or UFOs and I will answer that I
can't answer that really the CIA won't
let me yes kidding just kidding I'll
answer the alien I have never seen any
aliens or UFOs do I believe there's
alien life elsewhere in the universe
yeah I believe that I think there's life
there's there's so many trillions of
stars I think there will be life out
there that said I don't think they've
come here to visit because I think I
think if they ever do they're gonna make
a significant contact I was talking
today and I said if they come here I
think they'll land in LaGuardia or so
they'll and LaGuardia they're not
getting back or they're gonna be late
getting back that's for sure but I think
they would come and make a significant
impact to me and I do this obviously
tongue-in-cheek but I say you know it
doesn't make sense to me that some
brilliant alien civilization is gonna go
to the trouble of building an
interstellar spacecraft flying this
tremendous distances earth see they are
teeming with life and then only hover
over lonely Widow rancher ladies in New
Mexico and beer drink in New York
fishermen that that doesn't make sense
to me let's take one more question then
we'll start the book signing here
hi do you see China or other nations as
moving forward into a space travel China
and other nations moving forward China
certainly they've launched what two-man
missions now and China says they want to
go to the moon here in the next couple
years I don't believe that's gonna
happen I mean I think they're gonna
it'll take a significant number of years
before they're capable of doing
something like that but in India
certainly might someday have a man
program I I think probably it's gonna
get it's get it's so expensive I think
you're gonna see more and more
cooperative efforts as we see with the
International Space Station that
everybody is kind of pooling their
resources to make things happen in space
okay I tell you what why don't we uh
since it is what time I got here I've
been about talking up here for about a
half an hour so why don't we go ahead
and start the book signing and anybody
has a question while I'm sign you can
ask that thank you very much Mike
Mullane flew 134 combat missions in
Vietnam and has logged 356 hours in
space for more information visit Mike
Mullane com